there are are there any other
superheroes that you'd love to bring to
the big screen um I think spider-man
could do as a bit of help I think this
was there's some fun stuff that could
happen with spider-man always wanted to
make a Superman film I might suit my
movie would be incredibly different to
the Superman film that thou bear'st but
um I'll say I did a more colorful dick
donger that fit my ring is underwear
outside his pants you know yelling so I
do more Superman and I grew up on and
left well no that could have got all
blown out of proportion I mean I had a
very brief chat with them and that's all
it was okay so in it for the Pertino
from a 30-second chat I'm this fuchsia
thing so um so guys are football who is
the ideal Superman like would you go
would were you going to go with an
unknown were you thinking about an actor
in particular like what was your
direction that you want to haven't gone
that far because we just had an idea for
a story for Superman metaphor what do
you think about the fact that Boyer and
Chris Nolan I guess is god-bothering so
to speak this new Superman film I think
they're both talented surgeon it's a
good hand I just hope they don't make it
too serious I think that's the one thing
not suited man is try and do the serious
Dark Knight Busch you have Superman is
about color and fun should be yeah for
me with that the last of the last
Superman the Bryan Singer's version had
a I think it's a good stuff a little too
seriously or was it well yeah I was a
mess yeah I'd no idea what it was and
there was it a bit of remake was it a
prequel or a sequel I mean what was it
was I genuinely and I should think
writing is done from fabulous movies by
just felt that was just just a mess and
all the way of describing it
hey youtubers is Charlie so after doing
a video about Man of Steel earlier today
he's in preliminary talks right now to
direct the Man of Steel sequel I
couldn't not make a video when I found
out that he'd already talked about
making a superman film a long time ago
now the first clip was from Kingsman so
that was more recent but as you can tell
from the second clip that was from
earlier from like 2008 so they were
still ramping up to make the David Goyer
Zack Snyder Superman film so one I love
the idea of him doing a more
lighthearted Superman story one that's
not super crazy intense the way he sort
of talks about not doing it super
serious is funny because that's kind of
the way that man is still turned out it
was very real-world it ended up being a
very serious movie he does kind of crash
Superman Returns a little bit but back
during this time like before they'd
already announced that David Goyer Zack
Snyder we're going to be doing Man of
Steel and they were taking pitches there
was a Matthew Vaughn Mark Millar that's
right the comic book creator Mark Boal
our Superman movie pitch in since then
Mark Millar has explained what that
pitch was now it's pretty crazy so
clearly it's Matthew Vaughn ends up
directing the next Man of Steel movie
it'll be a very different story than
from what they pitched way back in
2008-2009 but here's what that pitch is
and this is directly out of Mark
Millar's mouth this is the way he talks
about the project so he says his version
of Superman is going to be like the
Michael Corleone in The Godfather films
the entire story from beginning to end
you see where he starts how he becomes
who he becomes and where that takes him
the Dark Knight showed you that you can
take a comic book property and make a
serious film and I think that the
studio's are ready to listen to bigger
ideas now the problem with Superman
Returns was like releasing Star Wars in
77 the Empire Strikes Back in 80 in then
waiting 28 years to release Return of
the Jedi it wasn't relevant I understand
what Bryan Singer was trying to do to
pay homage to Richard Donner's original
version but I think you should pay
homage by doing something completely
different so this is how he explains
that original pitch that he and Matthew
Vaughn had was going to be different he
says I want to start out on Krypton a
thousand years ago in end with Superman
alone on planet earth as the last being
left on the planet
the Yellow Sun turns red and starts to
supernova and he loses his powers so
right off the bat he's basically talking
about showing the entire life of
Superman
the real entire life of Superman because
remember he doesn't really age the same
way humans do because of his powers so
he will live to see the entire earth die
unless somebody else kills him like
doomsday well let me know what you guys
think about that original pitch it's
pretty crazy and very clearly the new
films will have a more hopeful tone
they've already said that Justice League
is going to be much more hopeful than
Batman V Superman that was sort of the
low point in the narrative so it was
always intended to be kind of a bummer
so Justice League was going to be a lot
more fun I think the Man of Steel sequel
if it's not man of tomorrow they'll do
something like Man of Steel rebirth or
Superman rebirth I feel like that would
actually be a great title just Superman
rebirth let me know what do you want
them to do and remember it's probably
going to be a couple years before we
actually get to see another Superman
movie it'll be sometime in the next two
to three years if they hire a director
in the next year it'll take them at
least a year to get a script out so I
think they want to have it drop before
the second Justice League movie or maybe
after depending on how quickly they can
get things going but new flash come in
tomorrow I'll be posting iron fist be
sure to subscribe to get that there's a
new round of the flash ring giveaway
that's going on right now so everything
is going to be great I'm so excited
about the idea of a Matthew Vaughn
Superman movie just remember that that
crazy Mark Millar Superman pitch is not
what the movie is going to be that's
from almost 10 years ago but while you
guys wait for that next video
you can click here to learn all about
saboteurs identity on the flash and you
can click here for the trailer for the
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
in the next video
you